In this class we have talked a lot about how AI agents must be able to
reason about the work. But the external work consists of systems from many
different kinds. A system is composed of heterogeneous interacting components.
The interaction within components, lead to processes of different kinds.
These processes can occur at many different of those abstraction.
Some of the processes might be invisible. Consider an ecosystem.
In an ecosystem, processes occur at many levels of abstraction. Physical,
biological, chemical. Some of these processes are invisible to the naked eye,
but they influence each other. Similarly in business, businesses are composed of
a large number of interacting units, manufacturing, marketing, delivery, and so
on. Each of these units can be described at many levels of abstraction, from
individuals, to teams, to full organizations. Given that the extra work consists
of systems of different kinds. Their agents must be capable of systems thinking.
They must be capable of thinking about the invisible properties of systems.
About the complex behavior of the systems. In particular,
they must be able to derive the invisible processes from the visible structure.
This is systems thinking.